in hong kong's shrinking media space
another loss in a statement on social
media independent online news site
citizen news said it would stop
operating from tuesday saying it needed
to ensure the safety of its staff it
described itself as a little boat in the
middle of tremendously rough seas
that announcement came less than a week
after stan news announced it would close
down hours after the independent
publication had been raided by police
and seven people were arrested in
october hong kong's security bureau
accused citizen news of misleading its
readers when reporting that free speech
was no longer guaranteed under the
national security law
founder chris young said although
citizen news had not been contacted by
national security police it was
impossible for the small outlet to
continue
overall media is facing a
an increasingly tough
environment
for those who are being seen as
critical or troublemakers they are more
vulnerable young said he hoped young
hong kong journalists wouldn't be put
off saying there's still a role for
media to play in the territory a
sentiment echoed by other journalists
there have been a lot of media workers
who expressed their sadness on social
media and i don't think we are the only
ones who suffered in this industry
there are still a lot of journalists who
are willing to try hard so i still have
hope citizen news is the third outlet to
shut down after stand news and hong
kong's last pro-democracy paper apple
daily that was forced to close in june
last year after its assets were seized
and founder jimmy lai arrested
authorities have also blocked programs
on public broadcaster radio television
hong kong and issued directives to staff
it's now uncertain how remaining outlets
including hong kong free press can
survive the decision by citizen news to
close is another sign that the media
environment here is becoming
increasingly difficult yet hong kong
authorities have repeatedly rejected
claims of a crackdown saying they are
not targeting the media journalism is
not sufficient but seditious acts and
activities
and inciting
other people through public access
activities could not be condoned
under the guise of news reporting hong
kong's chief secretary john lee
criticized a recent editorial published
in the wall street journal titled no one
is safe in hong kong saying that recent
arrests had nothing to do with media
freedom
hong kong was once known as a vibrant
hub for media outlets but a national
security law imposed on the region in
2020 has changed that and left many
fearing independent journalism is being
crushed britt clennan al-jazeera hong
kong